on y messieurs le président la question
s'adresse au premier ministre en 2014
en écho au président qui appelait de ses
voeux un choc de simplification le
parlement a adopté la fameuse loi dite
de simplification de la vie des
entreprises et début 2010 est après plus
de deux ans de souffrance l'heure est
venue de faire un bilan de cette
politique à destination des entreprises
oui je parle bien de souffrance car en
plus d'être malmené fiscalement depuis
2012 les entreprises et surtout les plus
petites d'entre elles doivent se plier à
ce qui est en fait une complexification
administrative très importante que ne
saurait cacher quelques mesurettes
brandi en étendard
le meilleur exemple de l'échec de cette
politique reste la mise en oeuvre du
conte pénibilité qui s'est encore
étoffée ces derniers jours avec l'entrée
en vigueur de référentiels
supplémentaires venant s'ajouter aux
facteurs et risques déjà défini
précédemment
les artisans tpe et pme s'avoue dépassés
par la complexité de l'établissement de
ce conte est leur interlocuteur dans
l'administration restant dans le flou
ils n'arrivent pas à se mettre à jour ce
qui entraîne des risques légaux pour ces
entreprises
je voudrais parler aussi de la mise en
oeuvre du prélèvement de la peau la
source qui donne bien des sueurs froides
aux patrons de tpe qui se voient obligés
de s'équiper à lure affret à grands
frais ou de faire appel à des
prestataires externes
au delà de l'affichage et des beaux
slogans du gouvernement l'administration
le plus grand mal à traduire cette
politique en mesures claires et c'est
tout le paradoxe en mesure simple tous
les acteurs économiques de terrain sont
les témoins atterré et les victimes
d'une incertitude généralisée de
contradictions administratives et de
l'explosion des critères à remplir pour
effectuer une simple démarche le triste
mais illustre exemple de cette absurdité
sont les multiples exceptions apporté au
principe selon lequel le silence de
l'accès de l'administration vaudrait
acceptation ainsi monsieur le premier
ministre
entre affichage et même si la parole est
à monsieur jean vincent placé
secrétaires d'état chargé de la réforme
de l'état et de la simplification
cachez votre joie monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député claude sturni
merci pour cette question équilibre et
merci aussi pour vos encouragements qui
me vont droit au coeur
mes félicitations républicaines
toutefois pour votre élection à la
communauté d'agglomération de haguenau
mais ce n'était pas le sujet du jour
plus sérieusement votre question
extrêmement à charge ne peut pas
correspondre à la vérité des faits parce
que notre administration depuis plus de
sept cents ans effectivement est devenu
centralise hâtive puissante et mis en
oeuvre des normes des règlements mais
ses normes et ses règlements ou un sens
elle protège nos concitoyens elle
protège l'environnement et protège votre
santé elle protège aussi nos solidarités
et la réalité est la suivante c'est que
oui aujourd'hui dans le monde moderne
aujourd'hui
eh bien il faut s'adapter en particulier
pour les entreprises et c'est pour cela
que le président république a voulu le
choc de simplification 2013 mais
pardonnez moi de vous dire que pendant
dix ans vous n'avez rien fait et que
vous arriviez bien facilement nous
depuis trois ans nous avons mis en place
une méthode collaborative avec le
conseil de simplification de la vie des
entreprises
plus de 800 mesure au vu le jour et je
vais vous en donner 3 simplement qu'ils
sont appréciés par les entreprises
marisol touraine a mis en place sa
déclaration sociale nominative
ce n'est pas moi qui le dit c'est air
sans news on peut pas dire ce sont des
officines gouvernementales 3,7 milliards
d'économies chaque à des poses
entreprises plus de vingt dispositif de
déclaration sociale fusionner l'ensemble
des entreprises françaises on est
particulièrement satisfaite
le marché public simplifiée grâce à nous
avec uniquement le code siret
aujourd'hui on peut soumissionner
grâce à bercy grâce au travail de michel
sapin et de questions et caire une
entreprise française peut se missionné
uniquement avec le code siret au marché
sain puisque et enfin 3 et mesuré jeu
confus là dessus grâce à ségolène royal
nous
la langue plus vite pour les éoliennes
nous avons fusionné la procédure tout à
la fois de permis de construire et
d'autorisation environnementale nous
faisons gagner plus de 18 mois aux
entreprises éoliennes et vous voilà paré
rotterdam cécile une terre meilleur